me time and taking care of yourself is
more important than ever right now
especially
for parents ebody renew is providing a
safe place for the whole family to
escape to while moms and dads relax
and kids play
[Music]
ibody renew is a family affair from the
owners to the team
to the clients i feel good about myself
when i'm here
maggie enjoys being here don't you babes
that's mommy daughter duo caroline and
magdalena you would think a fitness
instructor
didn't need to renew their body right
but caroline says and i quote
ebody renew is the cherry on the cake it
just helps everything just get slimmer
and stronger
and you know once i became painted with
my daughter had an incredible pregnancy
and then because of all the treatments
i'd done for so many years my body
bounced back within
three weeks four weeks hi my name is dr
gary lee and
i'm honored to be here at e-body renew
in madame monsieur
i've known them for many years and
fabulous people
and interestingly i've seen some amazing
results using the treatment
what we do ourselves is our specialty is
we teach doctors how to do
botox and wrinkles with juvederm
so we're focused on the face but you
know a lot of people are not only
focusing on their face they're focusing
on their body over the years ebody renew
has served as a relaxing getaway for
parents but
because of the pandemic parents can't
always have their much needed me time
owner ria has a solution we have a new
playroom for the children the mums are
very stressed out with kids out of
school
and my client here mary has
two little ones they're not at school
yet but you can imagine
three years and 11 months so
when she needs a break she can come here
and relax
and hey it's not all about the moms dads
need to be taken care of too
especially when they're under the care
of their own son well originally 10
years ago my dad here brought me to
e-body renew when i was 13 years old and
i lost
65 pounds in seven months and not only
did this treatment change my life
but it saved my life there's no doubt
without this treatment this nutritional
guidance
that i wouldn't be able to sit here and
share my story and let other people know
that there's hope out there
yeah so now i'm the patient and manson's
my therapist right
so we just completed six weeks i'm down
15 pounds i've lost four and a half
inches in the waist
and it's really awesome because you come
here
you go into a private room lie down
manson hooks me up to the machine
you relax you listen to beautiful music
let the machine do the work
and it's nice to feel that your clothes
are fitting loosely again
manson's dad decided to get the
treatment because he can't exercise due
to surgeries
so the non-physical workout e-body renew
provides is perfect for surgery recovery
and prep dr carter another member of the
e-body renew fam
would agree i had to have surgery
and i wanted to strengthen
my back and my muscles before
surgery and the reason is if you're more
strong and healthy before surgery
the outcome is better and so i came to
ebody sculpting because
the machines the machines do
more than one thing yes it helps with
weight reduction but it helps with
circulation
detox and strengthening the muscles
and all of that's very important that i
go
into surgery in the best possible way
that was their henderson location for
more information on e-body renew call
702-608-5857
off so call now we'll be right back